c'est non non monsieur le procureur
général des proches à la république
votre réquisitoire
ça va saigner
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public crie à mon
p'tit claude syrie comme s'ils étaient
bien nous deux je suis le président
j'aime quand tu me cogne avec ta grosse
ceinture cloutée quoi dans ça c'est le
courrier du ministre courrier de votre
courrier monsieur le président qui
traînent dans mon dossier c'est vraiment
inadmissible or moi ça me fait rater
tous les effets je reprends ici il seul
fait rire moi je reprends pouf pouf
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public syrie
regardez regardez cette espèce de cowboy
francophone hexagonal avec s'est tenue
débraillée de chanteurs sauvage et sa
grosse ceinture cloutée 6/2
n'at-on pas envie de lui couper la tête
avant même de savoir s'il est coupable
ou non
comme le disait si justement mon
arrière-grand-père le procureur adolf
von des proches que dreyfus soit
coupable ou pas qu'importe envoyons le
aubagne après quoi je le précise pour
l'anecdote on s'aperçut en effet que
c'était pas dreyfus qui avait fait le
coup c'était lévis mais revenons à nos
moutons ou plus précisément à nos
chèvres puisque disons le tout de suite
mon réquisitoire traitera du problème de
la chèvre je le dis d'emblée afin d
auditeurs sensible et le temps de
tourner le bouton de se brancher sur un
post périphériques pour faire joujou
attention même du genou pour 100 francs
marignan 415 407 branché voyeur oui
hélas mesdames et messieurs les jurés
alors que des milliers d'années de gens
de ce pays sont cloués au bistrot par le
chômage sont cloués à la maison par le
chômage galopant
que fait le sieur au frais il cumule
toute honte bue il chante d'une main il
élève des chefs de l'autre et encore si
elle devait ses chèvres avec amour mais
non ils les brutalisent je le crie bien
au afin que la spa m'entendais que
brigitte bardot montant d'1 brigitte
cité à l'ecoute lâche un peu ton phoques
et écoute ça
hugues aufray l'odieux cowboys cumulards
tape sur ses chèvres avec sa grosse
ceinture cloutée alors que la chèvre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés la chèvre est un
être sensible
vous le savez bien monsieur le président
vous qui comme l'a dit avant moi le
grand poète jean ferrat la chèvre est
l'avenir de l'homme
il est intolérable de laisser monsieur
offrait ici présence répondre en camps
se répandre en contres vérités anti
caprine ne niez pas monsieur au frais
n'était ce point vous qui déclarent y
ait au journal paris jour le 12 novembre
1967 la chèvre doit être passive obscur
et réservé peut-être parlez vous de la
femme mais pour vous la chèvre la fable
que ça c'est pareil mais j'en aurai fini
maintenant avec la chef monsieur le
président monsieur président m'excuserai
d'avoir été un peu long avec cette
histoire de chef je les fais en souvenir
de mon ami monsieur seguin qui
connaissait bien le sujet puisque son
gendre était légionnaire
mesdames et messieurs les jurés il nous
faut punir cet homme de même que doivent
être punis tous les odieux cumulards de
ce pays en prison l'éboueur infâme qui
non content de gagner des dizaines de
francs en réveillant les bourgeois dès
6h du matin
va ensuite faire l'homme sandwich le
soir pour quelques grands restaurants
afin de se faire encore plus d'argent et
notez au passage le cynisme de l'éboueur
les détritus du grand restaurant vont
remplir d'autres boubel que le même
éboueurs vivra le lendemain en ricanant
en prison également l'odieuse thénault
dactylo qui à peine terminé sa journée
de bureau
phildar d'art chez elle pour torcher ces
gosses faire le ménage et préparer le
retour du seigneur et maître autant
ainsi le pain de la bouche des vallées
de pied des cas mais restée autre femme
de chambre oui mesdames et messieurs les
jurés punissons les sténoses les
ouvrières qui n'ont pas d'employés de
maison et punissons enfin les ignobles
proxénète basané d'origine plus ou moins
portugaise qui rappelle relever leur
compteur à pigalle sans presse
d'endosser la robe noire de l'avocat
d'assises
dire leurs fins de mois en défendant des
chanteurs cumul à monsieur tout à
l'heure j'en ai terminé monsieur le
président messieurs mesdames et
messieurs les jurés je conclurai
sobrement en vous demandant de mettre
hugues aufray fait que mon nom
[Musique]